welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Allie smiley know that
Allie smiley who is the one of the
directors at soap yes
Allie yeah thanks for joining me may i
problem thank you looking forward to
this absolutely
normally I'll start with how did you get
into recruitment I'm gonna give you a
bit of a curveball mate soap yes where'd
that come from it is there a story yes
no yes no little bit it was it's it's a
bit about being heard it's it's about
giving our brand a voice okay and you
know standing on top of a soapbox and
being heard and yeah get the message out
there so that's where it kind of
originated from really yeah we get all
of our all client it is like I'm mad
naming me not just soap it's like so
much the other man yes so much so yeah
it was i but not yes so yeah and it's we
have a lot of clients and candidates are
asking about it so it stands out though
it does and that's what you wanted you
know is different there's a lot of funny
jokes conf about it about you know
trying to clean up the recruitment
industry if you look at sort of your
company website the colors and all that
like it does it's like it's in your face
yeah a brand we wanted a girlfriend
you've got to differentiate yourself for
so many recruitment agencies start in
any on a yearly basis you've got to do
something different so we were branding
our message you know everything we tried
to do has to be a little bit different
yeah that obviously like that must have
took a bit of getting used to their lot
hi my name's Ali I'm calling from so so
people I would you work for cleaning
company like yeah we get a lot of emails
as well from slope distribute distribute
our products so products alright cool
just wanted to get out there main
straightaway because I was thinking
about it so as you know we're always
like to start me and obviously were just
looking for your linkedin to refresh my
memory but how did ali enter the word
real criminate talk to me
so I was brought into the world of
recruitment by a friend the next
colleague of mine who's now my business
partners he yeah he approached me at
that time I had no experience in
recruitment always been in sales really
but yeah he was he got into recruitment
himself had some success and then was
growing out his team we actually bumped
into each other by chance after a
wedding at a friend's wedding
oh wow yeah yeah really by chance and I
nearly didn't go to that wedding because
I had actually been really ill a few
weeks before that like seriously ill and
I wasn't going to attend but it did and
fate has it bonne answer near bumped
into Olli and you had had a conversation
about what he was doing and you know
what what he was trying to do grow a
team and build a team where he was and
at that point I had quite a few friends
and people that I knew in the industry
say that it was you know I could be
suited to it never really actually
committed to exploring the opportunity
but yeah spoke to him about it and then
had some meetings and ended up joining
his team and yeah I guess it's always a
good thing to join the summer where like
you've got something you've got that
[ __ ] with you not me yeah someone you
trust someone who worked before someone
that you can you know you've got good
chemistry with and that was really
really important that's probably the the
biggest reason why I actually joined
okay and got into recruitment up until
that point nine because like obviously
your career as you said where did sales
is he working from in the banks to
estate agent to Account Manager yeah and
had you not dealt with recruiters during
that period then so my first experience
with recruiters was when I joined
coca-cola
I was I was reached out to by their
talent acquisition team so I had some
experience but they didn't that was the
first time I'd ever been approached by a
recruiter and a couple of and maybe
before that had also had some recruiters
put me into some jobs but I never really
I never understood their job fully but
yeah I had I had some contact there when
I wanna join coca-cola and yeah but it
wasn't something that I
I thought I would do it wasn't there
ever thought that it could be a career
for me it was never something that I
thought I could pursue and make a career
out of so what just just to finalize
that what was your perception and
recruitment then before you joined Ollie
and his team I just thought I thought
recruitment was people sitting in
cubicles you know ringing out calling
cold calling trying to you know get
people to move their their current job
to a new job it just didn't it didn't
really appeal to me but I guess I never
ever dug deeper than that than the
surface level yeah I met sense okay yeah
so then joined Ollie yes and that was
business cause starting May and yeah he
was there for just under three years and
then he left there and then has
obviously been part of the soap journey
for yeah from day one yeah and being
involved of that yeah so so how long you
been in recruitment now nearly five
years five years yeah yeah is that
career for you now
absolutely yeah I couldn't it's so it's
so strange so I couldn't imagine doing
anything else for me you know it really
fits me personally you know the goals I
want to achieve the type of personality
I have I think a lot of the traits that
even something I didn't probably know I
had within me I think they've really
developed since I've come into into
recruitment so as an individual I've
grown so much in the last four or five
years and I've always been quite
confident in myself but I didn't really
know what I was capable of doing until I
was put into the position where I had to
really you know build out something for
myself and and show that
entrepreneurialship so I think that's a
big thing in recruitment if they throw
out a word you know entrepreneurial so
much but then it's very cliche but it's
so true yeah you know yeah yeah I think
just just something has popped into my
head mode which i think is interesting
and your journey like how old how old
was you when you got into recruitment
and joined Olly
I was probably yes very late twenties
early thirties so probably on that's
interesting yeah so you know I mean
cause like I just for that just because
like do you thing typical recruiter an
owner or manager Ron I'm hiring for my
team who do you initially think of it's
like young young totally growers are
because
so you had done quite you were some
different industries blah blah blah I
think nothing this is interesting point
because I think that yet typically
historically those the kind of
individual you look for right people
they were willing to put in the hard
yards put in the hours and I didn't come
from a recruitment background at all I'd
come from a sales background but I feel
that maybe that's why I've had some of
the success I've achieved so far it's
because I didn't come from a recruiting
background I was a more mature
individual yeah and I think that allowed
me to understand that the job better I
think it allowed me to be able to
perform the functions I think you know
when you come in and you're very green
you're young it can be daunting prospect
and also you have to be able to
experience highs and lows of recruitment
and when you've had you know other sales
roles where you've dealt with you know
the ups and downs I think that really
helps you going into this type of job
because there is ultimately going to be
ups and downs and it's about how you
deal them and I think you know being a
bit more mature and being the age that I
was maybe was one of the big reasons why
maybe now I'm seeing a lot more success
ya know it's really interesting because
I think if I think when I started it
like obviously what you had under your
belt is is which isn't maybe a typical
someone is just joining the industry
typically may not have his lot a lot of
experience right even though it's still
very much young late twenties early yeah
yeah like it can be quite daunting early
on if I when I started like speaking to
people about their careers who are like
thirty five you know that ages of thing
but speaking that are a lot more older
news and like that and so I guess the
life experience you're having about
absolutely definitely equip you have
more tools to relay or what I mean
interesting 100 person okay so what I
always like to speak to people about is
their first year in recruitment so as
you just said you feel like you things
everybody starts come to fruition now
yeah which obviously I know about
because you shared with me like let's
just just cost back to what it was like
first in recruitment as we're just
talking about you've got this life
experience you've got the PD experiences
it helped you deal with the highs and
lows but how was those first twelve
months but really for me I probably set
a car crash really really didn't yet
it wasn't it wasn't how I wanted it it
wasn't how I expected it to go maybe
I've been a bit naive maybe I thought it
would I would you know sort of get into
it a lot better than I did but it wasn't
it wasn't plain sailing for me at all
and I think again that's probably helped
me you know to get to where I am now but
you know had good training I had good
mentors I still do now but I think my
first year I think a lot of it's
interesting because I saw you mentioned
something about you know the tenure of
the average recruitment consultant being
in 13 months right yeah so I think if
you get to the point where you know
after the first year it's not happening
for you a lot of people might just think
to throw in the towel there yeah
sometimes less man yeah probably
sometimes less and to be honest I
probably could have I probably could
have done that myself but for me was
kind of a sink or swim situation you
know I had a young family I made a
commitment to myself that was if I was
gonna leave the role that I was in
before I'd run recruitment which was
pretty comfortable for me then I had to
make it work yeah so I saw the long game
but really my first year was you know
what was great like I remember one I
caught them in the exact number but I
don't think it was any more than 50
grand really yeah really it was was it
was it more or less than 24k nothing
okay let's just talk a bit about that
for a sec yeah a bit of big a big reason
why I started this was because of my
experiences in the first year so as you
said it was a car crash didn't build a
lot you said that you could have very
much quit being one that so yeah so
firstly why do you not quit again like I
said it was a hundred percent
sink-or-swim for me I'd made the
decision lux at having young family and
I wanted more I was in I was in quite a
comfortable job which you know paid well
but it wasn't something that I could
ever see myself getting to where I
wanted to be with and I think the thing
with recruitment is and again it's so
cliche but it's so true is
you really can fast-track your career
yeah and I was I bought into that dream
I bought into that opportunity and I
thought I had to commit and giving
something a year is just not long enough
and I've had you know I had to make that
decision that if I'm gonna commit to it
I need to give it enough time and for me
to learn because I came into it
completely blind yeah you know not you
know no experience whatsoever just
purely sales so for me there was no
there was another option fitted them for
me to continue so that that was really
the driving force for me was that if I
if I didn't do it I was one year away or
one year further away from being where I
wanted to be okay I like that
did you or did you always typically have
that mindset do you know what it's come
back to what I said earlier as well like
I did but I didn't know how much I did
until I got into recruitment and because
a lot of the onus will fall on you you
know it's it's all down to how much you
want it you can carve out whatever you
want for yourself is the amount of work
you put in you know the amount of effort
it will show in in what you Bill in what
you can achieve and to fast rate your
career to where I am today you know
compared to where I would have been if I
stayed where I was before I'm old
business there's just no where would
have been you know you know fast track
my career the way I did so yeah that's
that's obviously the great great great
thing was about recruitment absolutely
say okay then so just quickly what would
you say that and was the biggest
challenge for you in that first year but
what was the thing that you really
struggled to get to grips with that's
worth just talking about for a second
what did you find most difficult I think
at that time what I didn't realize it
was it was probably more personal
reasons outside of work okay
at the time my mother was really ill it
was very difficult time for me that I
didn't really I didn't realize how much
it affected to me until I was out of
that situation until it passed but on a
daily basis I think getting getting my
head around the jobs you know getting my
head around you know the market you know
really committing myself to becoming a
master in my market I think until I
decided to make almost become obsessed
with everything at
being you know knowledgeable you know
knowing exactly who my clients were who
their competitors were yeah you know
knowing the candidates I think when I
made that decision that constant
decision to you know really commit to
knowing that and dedicating and becoming
obsessed I think I was just coasting and
it just it wasn't it wasn't until I
tasted a little bit of you know the
Billings you know the earnings that I
thought you know holding a minute this
is you know this is really that there
there's so much potential here that's
interesting
so that was yeah that was a big turning
point the last question to run that so
obviously totally get personal
circumstance yeah that's obviously
really difficult and then hindsight it's
a great thing right well actually that
did definitely impact my mental game
these sorts things but if you was to go
back and get yeah how would you approach
it differently life we think of people
listening they're a year in or whatever
like or early on how would you approach
it differently do you think I think are
definitely so I think the biggest thing
is to and again as quickly Shea but it's
just so true is knowing your market you
know you need to know your market and
you don't need to be an expert but you
need credibility and I think as soon as
you start becoming credible and people
trust in you because that's the hardest
thing is gain people's trust both a
client on the candidate side you only
have a small period of time to do that
especially on the first on on a
potential first phone call I think you
know committing myself to become
incredible to understand what I'm
positioning how am i different from the
other ten recruiters that have contact
this individual that same day in some
cases I think that's the biggest turning
point from I think as soon as you
understand that you know don't take
anything for granted don't be don't take
it to heart or to seriously they used to
be times when you know I might hit the
post with a candidate you know they
might get an offer or might have
rejected it or you know sort of been
rejected at final stage whatever it may
be is to not let it affect you that's
that is so hard you know thanks so hard
and that is one thing that I felt that
maybe set me up for where I am now is I
had a lot of that in the first year and
that really hardened me up to the point
where you just have to get on with you
have to move on I think if you can deal
with that
heartbreak and all that at the beginning
then it gives you a better chance to
yeah you know push on further down the
line if you have things all your own way
to begin with you often think it's quite
easy you know that's a really good point
so just quickly on that yeah and knowing
your market these sorts of things I
think all I would say on that I think if
I was listening right now
and I was early on it is because I speak
to people that when I sort of work with
people sometimes they might have a
lesson and years experience whatever and
a real challenge for people is is
feeling like they know their market and
having a confidence like they know their
mark even though they're like six months
twelve months yeah yeah to go what I
mean
absolutely that is difficult at the
beginning to truly believe that you're a
monster and obviously it's a process so
I guess just a quick one on that may
obviously also you're gonna be speaking
to Canada it speaking clients in terms
of consistently learning about them that
are there but how much was your doing
outside of work out of interest okay so
and again this is I think a big
difference so outside of work it's
interesting because I don't think that
compared to now probably hardly anything
at the beginning at the beginning I was
and there was other circumstances I was
commuting from from Brighton to London
you know I was leaving it getting trains
at like 6:00 in the morning you know
again up at 5:00 getting trains at 6:00
in the morning to be at the office of
Courts away having a full day they're
getting a train back at like half six
quarter seven and getting through the
door probably back nine o'clock so at
grim that it was it was very grim but
that definitely contributed to it and
these are the things I did I don't think
I'll realize until until the time passes
might you say hindsight's yeah yeah but
until that time passed and went and I
reflected I thought okay there were
there were challenges but there's always
going to be challenges right yeah and it
and I think like I said earlier you you
know now to the point where I'm quite
obsessed with everything to the point
probably where I don't close my laptop
or yeah fine over enough I think if you
put that effort in and it's I say this
to the people we hire within our
business at the moment you know the
associates coming in is you you've got
to be prepared to go above and beyond if
you're not going to do something
different to all the other recruiters
out there
then you can't expect different results
if you want to be the best if you want
to have the best market knowledge if you
want to know you know everything about
your candidates you you need to do
something different you need to do what
others aren't willing to do and I think
when you make that commitment you can
you can see so many results out of this
and I think it's just directly impacted
by that when when was that moment then
for you off is like a teen moment yeah
yeah about 18 months to using when I
went and actually worked internally for
a vendor which really helped me I think
when I work and when does it stop man
know when I left stop my wind went and
did a contractor vendor understood how
they work from from within you know how
they work with stakeholders the
processes and some of the challenges
they face that game you're really
rounded understanding so from both sides
of the fence and then really when you
know when I started it and you know it's
soap just again I think it's that
sink-or-swim mentality right when you
have to make something work yeah you'd
have you do whatever you can you've got
to do whatever it takes and as soon as I
my mindset switched and you know I
started really doing you know spending
more time more hours investing in in my
development that's when I when
everything clicked for me so didn't
click or stop there just it just didn't
it doesn't have me it just bro that's
like I'm just on the free is yeah no no
it's a long happen II just didn't happen
for me it just and I mean it's nothing I
don't think it's it's got anything to do
with anyone there or I take full blame
you know so how did you stand that role
mate I'd like what made you stay on that
but you know I mean difficult you know
what that it's it's hard because
everyone you know they're taking a leap
of faith on you yeah you know the
pressures on you're feeling the pressure
because you want to deliver but it's
just not quite happening there's you
know and I'm I'm the kind of person that
takes all the blame on you know there
there's I don't like playing the blame
game there's only one person that's
responsible for the outcome and that's
and that's me definitely so for me
personally it was difficult it was
challenging but there wasn't really
anyone else to blame I had the tools
that I needed you know I was trained
well I had a good mentor there wasn't it
just was one of those
it just didn't quite happen to me and
I'm usually over the years I've been
successful at what I've done and I've
really tried hard to achieve targets and
goals and no really push myself but it
just for whatever reason it just it just
didn't happen for me how did you keep
your job afterwards that's a real
question ya know I mean cause like yeah
that's mad yeah I mean it don't get me
wrong it wasn't it wasn't you know I was
still billing but it wasn't fireworks I
mean we worked over 100k so we then
worked we then worked on a on a team
basis and myself another yeah another so
basically was underneath let's say 360
and then I was myself delivering another
colleague that was delivering so we
worked off a team so effectively we got
team commission yes we got team
commission yeah yeah yeah yeah
so effectively put this way so we we
worked together as a team so we could
effectively help ourselves and each
other out on the mumps where one of us
maybe didn't do so great there might
have been caught as where one person did
really well another didn't but we had
that relationship between each other
that's really good we're all friends we
all knew each other and we were all
prepared we all prepare to do that we
were all on board with that that wasn't
something that was put upon us that's
something that we agreed with really
together yeah so really in all lessons
that was probably one of the main
reasons but as a team we did deliver but
personally I would defer to you felt
like you could have grown 100%
hundred-percent
okay just just quickly because it's the
first time this we've spoken about this
and I don't obviously we won't make the
assumption like this is what it's like
for us the whole company with will
you're within your time there you grid
as a team that you're gonna do it in a
team approach like how the hell did that
work Commission wise just quickly
because that wit that yeah it wasn't it
it's so effectively we got paid a team
commission the 360 individual who owned
the clients and the count relationships
they obviously got a larger part of the
of the Commission but then it always
meant that me and the other individual
my colleague we always got something you
know in a way meant that we which in
essence actually wasn't two bags it was
meant that you've got some type of
Commission yeah but it also didn't mean
it was never any fireworks
yeah
so it could have been better but it
could have been worse
you know the mumps you don't build and
you're not getting any Commission you
know yeah often recruiters base
commission isn't very good so in essence
it actually didn't work out too badly
but of course it was you know when you
get into recruitment you're getting into
it for the big paychecks you know you
want in that success you want the you
know the big Commission but it
definitely didn't happen for me there
and it was it was really tough because
you know it's a long period not to have
that taste and I was always having
conversations with my mentor and we're
always you know he was always you know
believing in me telling me that you know
I could do the job that I it was just a
matter of time you know he that the
belief there was one of the big reasons
which kept me going could you do team
commissioned again be honest yeah I
think now there's fireworks yeah I think
do you know what we've you know we've
got a system it's so we're and I think
it's a little bit different it's not the
same talk to what we were doing at start
may so actually it there's there's good
and bad bits that and also I'm investing
in the people we bring in you know what
was once an associate and for me it's
nice to you know one of my you know part
of my job is to it's to progress them
you know as men to help them and get
them to where they want to be just just
like I was there
eventually Malcolm's in Commission yeah
it's it's not for everybody and I think
it's important to it's important to help
out the individuals around you and if it
if it you know essentially if it gets
them to where they need to be it's a
business to where it needs to be then
you say this that's so interesting
yeah teen Commission yen sets last us
really interesting I was on the phone
something of a day he said they had seen
Commission and I was just lying on my
good days yeah I don't think I could
ever do that but well I just wanted so
actually quickly before we really dig
into sort of that moment experience and
sort of the journey run now and sort of
what you've been able to achieve because
I think that that's where a lot of
people get values so you mention on
cement or a few times
talks a little bit about that because
that's something that I'm really
passionate about and yeah a lot of
people can benefit from so and was that
this mental was it someone within the
business was it yeah okay and how did
this relationship form them was it
something that the business promoted
does this happen organically
yeah he's I'm still with him now so he
basically he's the individual that
brought me into the business he was he
mentored me okay well and then was he
your manager yes yeah so and everything
that I essentially learn mmm majority of
it came through him really there were
other senior stakeholders in the
business you know the team leads
individuals that I still work with today
as well who had a big input but most of
it came through him okay
and really importantly something that
I'm trying to you know trying to just
tell me a bit about how did that how did
that then you'll see how did you then
and how does that become yeah mentor
obviously this person was your manager
yeah so what what what was the sort of
slight differences in terms of look made
it a bit more of a mentor oh I mean we
because it was is that the relationship
actually evolved that way
okay the relationship obviously I knew
him personally we were friends we'd work
together before we'd always been very
close and we'd grown up in the same
circles but then when I came into the
businesses start in May it was you know
with him all the time we traveled up to
London together we've got the train
together he essentially taught me he
gave me the training program he or he
was one of the individuals that came up
with a training program and delivered
the training program so he invested a
lot of time into me 100% we have quite
similar personalities we butt heads a
little bit as well because we're quite
similar but at the same time we share a
lot of the same interest the passion the
drive you know we do share a lot of the
same trade so it was quite easy to learn
off him and so yeah and I think he found
it easy to work with me as well and and
to deliver hit the message so yet to be
you know wouldn't I wouldn't be where I
am today 100% like it lasting for move
on
just because I remember I'm personal
conversations this came up big bill is
that stopped me yeah
seen any of those when you're there yes
yep
what so few what did you know these
people okay so what did I know about CP
these people were dedicated 100% knew
their market always consistent always
always consistent was that in what they
were doing on a daily basis
yeah all daily basically it's more than
consistent always seen their name on the
border where it's like you know in it's
it's on I keep I say the word obsession
quite a lot I think you have to be I
think you have to be to be at that level
where you can where you can build X
amount you know you and you're out or
quarter in quarter out it's tough it's
difficult there's so many things need to
take in consideration so many different
factors that a lot of them are outside
of your control there's only so much you
can control which is yeah which is
really interesting with recruitment
because you know control the
controllables and then the rest of it
there isn't much you can do about it try
your best to you know influence but I
think every every individual that I saw
had very similar traits and it was the
fact they were very very consistent they
would dedicate a day and day out
they always you know they always
performed it was very rare that you saw
them have like an off day or a bad day
it was keeping a real high level of
intensity and that's hard and it
definitely it definitely inspired me
that's one thing that I noticed that you
know seeing these individuals walk
around the office yeah you know there
there was a an aura around these people
right and it it motivated me you know
one of the first things I saw when I
went into the you know the office was
near the wall had all the money on it in
the Billings and everyone was right and
I was like wow I had no idea what it
meant
yeah and how it was how the Commission's
worked but when I saw the numbers on the
port on the wall I thought you know this
is wow yeah wow so you know one of the
first weeks I think I was there mark
this is just you know
the unreal type of money so yeah okay
interesting
so then left on me obviously started so
yeah with business partner yes
how long you into that journey now over
two years it's over two years just over
two yes and talk to me a bit about the
bingham of that journey mate definitely
gonna be easy not lose you it was a it
was it was myself two other colleagues
are like I said after we did our
internal sting we then basically got
into position where we we wanted to we
had our own ideas we had our own ideas
of that we had our own message I felt
after we worked internally for a vendor
and really understood some of the
challenges they face how long did you do
that for six about six months okay let's
just focus on that for a sec yeah just
because I think there's so much fun gal
that so let's just talk a bit about as
you just send them sorry mate six months
so that you start your journey move
sorry yes six months at this vendor yeah
so when you say vendor you're in the
cyber security space top security so
okay so you worked internally so let's
just share with everyone what were the
real challenges that you saw within this
business on the recruitment side you
know and then also let's think about how
much did you get involved like like as a
recruiter what were some of the horrific
things that you saw among the agencies
that tries it did you know I mean it was
I think the real big challenge was
aligning stakeholders aligning people
ensuring everybody was on the same page
because you've got you've got hiring
managers and stakeholders in different
regions different cultures different
communication styles who want one thing
then you've got ta who have another
objective which is not too dissimilar to
the stakeholder in that region but they
have an objective they need to achieve
and then even HR and the finance side of
things you have so many different
business units and stakeholders that of
course all one that the common end goal
which is to hire somebody yeah but
they're not always aligned and I think
that was the biggest iOpener was that
being on the other side of the fence as
an agent in an agency
and thinking over the years like you
know getting disgruntled with the TA
team to hiring managers yeah you know
why haven't they offered a candidate or
you know some of the challenges you face
you don't actually realize how they come
about until you're in that position
yourself in essence which is where we
found ourselves and and actually it
really gave us an insight into the daily
challenges that that they go through and
it really allowed me to understand the
the their position and what I can do as
an agent differently to try and help
them and I think that was really
interesting because it gave me the it
gave me an insight into the businesses
the top businesses that I was you know
working with yeah but really get to
understand the internal workings and it
was really really invaluable that's
that's crazy that you even you found it
a challenge being internal within the
walls at the state you know outside
wouldn't that's great it just doesn't
not a whole lot you know of course a lot
changes but there's different there's
different challenges and I don't think
you really understand that it's tough
it's really tough you know these are
sometimes hyper growth you know vendors
they're experiencing huge growth that
are willing to invest in bringing people
you know into their teams globally but
things things happen so quickly things
can change so quickly you know the idea
is the budgets there's so many things
that can change and then like I said you
got different people different
stakeholders within different business
units all pulling right different who
all want different things and mean so
hard that was the biggest challenge to
try and align everybody to get that
common goal so with that in mind then
definitely people listening in their
market that aren't in your world
I definitely experienced the same
challenge often yeah that's fair to say
so let's just share everyone then may
with that with that challenge that you
saw the Inspira ins
how can people and how do you approach
now getting yeah getting the
stakeholders within within the clients
that you work with more aligned like how
do knowing what you know now howdy how
can you try and get these people are
like Alliant it's it's I think it's
communication understanding that the
main drivers from all the stakeholders
involved what are the main drivers that
they
they don't have because effectively some
of them will be the same and it's trying
to line them all together yeah and
getting them to work to achieve that
that end goal that that is a tough side
but if you can if you can have some
control over the process I think now
that now that I'm out you know in the
age you know back in agency and you know
working with the clients we do today
it's I think the process is it's China
is trying to understand and having
control over the recruitment process
that is really important and when I
worked internally I've got an insight
into how how it works when when you're
from the outside you don't really have
that much visibility you journey toll
what you're told
yeah sometimes you don't have it you
don't have any exposure to hiring
managers you know you might not you know
you might just work purely with the TA
that's that's the policy some benders
have right so then that there isn't a
huge amount you can do but if you can
you know have that that that direct line
and you can create some type of control
that you know these are the types of
things that gave me a better
understanding about and I really think
maybe that's a big reason as to why now
I'm having a lot more success because I
understand better how these companies
work internally yeah I think that's a
really good point so firstly you need to
actually understand who's involved in
making and making this hire or who's
involved in enabling me to put this
person into this business whatever and
then again filling that down so right so
there's there's three people involved
hiring manager and only the business and
ta yeah just making it up and actually
then treating those people as
individuals and why it's important to
them to get that and some of them may be
the same as you've already said some of
them might be the difference so then
when I'm speaking to TN going look Suzie
mmm
like this is where we're at with things
bah blah blah remember you told me why
this is really important to get this
higher you know yes ya got your
headcount targets blah blah blah yeah
and then you're on the phone to Jim
who's a hiring manager go look Jim like
this is where at with it blah blah blah
you know you tell me like this is gonna
nobody hit your quota target exactly
does that fit still inside you is that
fair to say that absolute
so I think a lot of people can benefit
from that like don't treat everyone with
this that they will have this awesome
has the same objective absolutely the
same drivers and I'm assuming that you
then if you really make the tons of
understandings people an individual
Basin ended with drivers you can then
exact influence and exactly and also
they it's often it's also the types of
individuals that these people are
looking for and we find it quite often
with the client that we were today it's
like you know that the the stakeholders
in different regions might have an idea
of what they want yeah then the HR NCA
team they might have a different opinion
on what they're looking for and it's
actually sometimes they're not even
aligned on the top person they want so
it can be so challenging this and these
are the things that it's quite difficult
because you can try and have control on
you probably won't control and
everything but the reality is you're not
going to get that so it's about trying
to influence in control where you can
and then guide the process but you know
ultimately you can't have control over
everything but understanding
communicating with your clients and
understanding them as people I think is
so close to it's so important sorry to
understand who you're working with you
know their own values you know what that
that individuals about what he's looking
for or what she may be looking for in
the type of people they want to bring in
I think the better you understand the
bigger picture the more the more chance
you have of delivering value to your
customer and that's that's you know the
bottom line is what what are you going
to do differently you know how can you
provide better value than than your
competition yeah you're just touching it
then just to get your thoughts on when
you say can like obviously try and
control the recruitment process stuff
like that I mean you surely you like now
on obviously didn't different clients
blah blah blah you're limited time like
what for you then no no now blah blah
blah like what what part of the
recruitment process is like really key
to you that you have influence over and
did you know I mean that's difficult yes
it's tough and again every client is
different and they all have different
they all have different processes they
all have different rules of engagement
in terms of engagement you know you
never I don't think any two clients are
the same I just think it's really
important to ensure that you you and the
individuals that you're working with are
all aligned I think it's good
to have timelines in place I think it's
really important to as to understand
what that what your client wants how
they're gonna well how they're going to
achieve that and what they're what
they're also willing to do what are they
willing the effort the commitment
they're willing to make for you to also
achieve your your end goal because it's
it's a partnership and I think when
everybody's aligned it including the
agent I think this that you can create a
really streamlined process and again
that's that's obviously in an ideal
world but I think having having the
ability to speak with meet with these
people really understand what they're
looking for you you that's the only way
I think if you if you if you treat it as
it too much of a numbers game you're not
you're not going to get the outcomes you
want and you won't you won't be as
targeted so I think having that you know
speaking with them meeting them
understanding you know the really in
detail what they need what they want and
then also getting the commitment from
them that is really important because
without that it you know the process is
you know interviewing things can take so
long and then you know that time kills
deals that's what that's the big thing
yeah so the longer things goes on the
longer process can take it can really
affect the outcome okay so how is all of
this and how you're approaching things
and sort of your perspective on all this
impacted your performance than me I
think I think that's what's been the big
difference for me I think that now that
now that I had that experience you know
understanding how the internal companies
work understanding how my clients worked
I think that's really allowed me to
position myself better with my clients
okay allowed me to add more value to
them and essentially allowed me to build
more because I'm able to control better
the process than I did before don't get
me wrong it's not perfect it's always
room for improvement
we just have more of an understanding
that's definitely the difference between
what I was doing before and what I'm
doing now so what you're on track to do
this year mate come on
well you're hoping plus 300 plus 300
yeah yeah yeah yeah good pipeline for q4
well that will that be a big issue
a year before 180 I think under a
hundred eighty yep let's talk about this
for a sec yep I think a real comment and
thinking of it just a couple of more
things I want to go into real common
thing that people ask me about as
business development and then that's
something that you feel pretty strongly
about and you're talking about the
client piece blah blah blah so but just
just for a sec let's sort of go into
sort of alley work and I start on May
being a bit of a flop yep now obviously
being part of the soap journey but in
100k a hundred eighty K in your first
year to now hoping to break their
friends okay Martin like actually a
pretty hefty jump and yeah different
circumstances you're now in yeah so
let's break this down a bit cuz I think
a real common thing that people ask me
is Hisham I'm at this sort of 200 K Mart
250 came out on a Britannian okay mark
I'd love for you to talk to people about
how they've broken through that Plateau
do not I mean let's talk about that so
I'm sure some of the things already
spoke and may contribute to this as you
were just saying but yeah how how do you
think
and what part key parts have sort of
contributed to you you know potentially
being able to break that friends became
I think so the first the big thing was I
soon as I joined soap I was doing 360
wrong so I was doing had my own clients
where I was going and delivering on my
client before that I was not doing
purely delivery but it's something that
I really I felt that I fell into really
well I've always been in previous sales
well I've always been quite new business
focused it wasn't something that a
problem with you know trying to reach
out to new clients and leveraging my
network and relationships to get
meetings and bring on new roles I
actually you know I actually enjoy that
and that's a really strong part of my my
abilities but I think that like the
difference is now is that it's working
working roles that you know you can fill
is really important I think working the
quality of job something we're really
hot on is making sure you invest your
time working on the roles that you have
a much higher chance of filling whether
that's about the control you have the
relationship you have with the client
that relationship maybe invest your time
on filling those roles where you've got
better chances quit one so it's about
yep how do you measure if it's a
fillable raw okay so we've we've we've
got our own we've got our own analyzer
give it to me come on
so we so basically it's a brainchild of
one of the the directors and he's a he's
very very creative with this kind of
stuff and there's something actually a
new process that he's put in where we
kind of analyze our clients and we look
at we score them and rate them okay but
four different things on you know from
many things we talked about earlier you
know what kind of relationships you have
who you're speaking with budget for
roles time to hire you know have they
got interviewed cetera arranged quite a
few different things we then give them
each of those a score okay you do person
yeah personally we've gone out of five
out of five and then we rate them at the
end so you get this the final figure
yeah and then you can gauge there's it's
quite interesting cuz then you can
actually golden a minute I thought I had
a really good this you know this was a
really good client of ours what we've
got really good quality jobs and then
you actually look at it and you think
holding a minute actually it didn't
score as high as I thought it would you
know where can I make differences what
are the key metrics again sorry they'll
feel that's really useful for people
tonight yeah so there's there's quite a
few different things but will the core
map we write on so the relationship we
have right with one how do you measure
that though just lie it who with how
like for example how often you speaking
with these and then with the clients
yeah do you have weekly calls you
speaking to TA you speaking to a hiring
manager it's just someone you work with
before now all contributes to the
relation exactly they're you know how
they got budget for a role yeah do you
have are the exclusive terms are you
working retained yeah are you there's so
many this there's quite a few different
things right and then that spits out an
overall numbers like X means that this
is let's say out of let's just say out
of 20 let's have 20 and you score 10
you're like a minute that's I thought
was gonna be higher than that and then
the then that allows you and also allows
you to see where you could be week on
the account and where you could see
there
it's a really really good tool and that
gives us a chance to really understand
what level of service were providing for
our clients at the moment and where we
can improve and you know there's always
areas where you think you can improve
but it's also down to the client as well
to work with you and it's actually quite
a good tool to use to show them and say
you know we've actually we gain feedback
from the clients on this and it's um
it's quite interesting to get their
feedback because it also allows them to
see maybe whether they're slightly weak
so if you've got a good relationship
with the internal talent acquisition
teams you can position this in a way
where it's actually beneficial for them
to understand you know how how it is or
what it looks like for an agency to work
with them
so actually gear I totally get that so
it's like look ta like typically where
our best relationships where we offer
the best value exactly typically right
around this what I've noticed is right
now we're poor in these areas exactly if
if you're serious about getting 20 when
I get to achieve your target exactly why
we need to invest that so I think that's
wicked so just quickly before you talk
about other things so definitely
couldn't agree more work jobs that you
can fill yeah and you've become really
good at that
yeah unclear to think this system are
they so for someone listening right now
who Ali this sounds great
however it sounds a bit complex blah
blah blah from your experience yeah what
have you always made sure out of all
those metrics typically if it's one or
two things one thing that you make sure
it's scoring high would you say like you
know I mean you think you've always
you've always got to ensure that you're
staying close to the market you speaking
to candidates whether they're new or old
keeping in touch a really interesting
thing is I made I've made a lot of
placements with candidates who I
initially didn't have success with with
placing or getting them interest with a
role right a lot of people may just make
an assumption assumptions a really bad
thing to do you should never assume well
I don't know if I I don't know if I'm a
that a question clear we're gonna go
into there yeah see what I just wanted
for me so yeah was like you know you're
talking about the metric yeah all I just
wanted you to sort of say was like right
fight if there's one thing yep or two
things three things whatever
yeah that you you that you always make
sure that your client scores high on all
clients my bad so well I just wanted to
sort finalize that was your sorry sorry
this sounds great i'm sanna needs to be
making sure that I'm measuring my
relationships I'm working for libel joy
okay yeah yeah yeah so why does want to
say was if someone's listening right now
and they're like right so all see I'm
maybe it'd be a bit difficult to measure
all the metrics and they don't have this
blah blah blah but I listened to this
podcast and Ali said if I always make
sure the xxx is always scoring higher I
feel really strongly about it that's
going to mean that I'm gonna have the
best possible chance for doing the job
yeah do you know I mean so you always
make sure it's always at the level of
engagement right so the term zaqqum
commercial terms but the level of
engagement with the with the client so
okay whether it's I mean obviously
retained it always the best but the
exclusive having exclusivity yeah on a
roll for a period of time yeah
the better relationship of course the
more trust you'll have but and even
proven yourself and what I've done over
the past with with new clients is always
ask them to measure me on my success and
giving me a chance and give me an
opportunity to prove myself on a set
period of time and then if I don't then
then fine yeah I haven't I haven't
proven myself to you and I always find
that because that's given me an
opportunity to produce and in put me
under pressure okay so it's so it's
ultimately there's a lot of factors that
go into it but if you're listening right
now really think about the level
engagement level even clients are giving
you their you have jobs for perhaps like
even as much as either returning your
cause yes are they giving you interview
for you back quickly exactly are they
are they willing to give you a chance to
see if you can deliver blah blah so
there's a lot of things that go into it
but all totally the core of it is if
you're listening right now and you want
to build more let's look at your client
take about look at your clients a lot
right who do I have the best
relationships over now and fingers out
how engaged are they in with you and
these exactly that exactly quali exactly
that all right cool so and then
obviously as you ascend mate stories a
button I suppose ones about that clear
so like as we were talking about like
how has a league on to this point we're
looking at broken frames of Kmart so
you're talking about then what other
things come to mind for you then so what
other things you think not me not not be
complacent not assuming like I said
early not assuming shillings big enough
it's I used to be quite bad it's the
mother of all as you know yeah it's so
easy I remember it's so clearly it's
like it's so easy at the beginning
because there's an element of light been
the bit rely bit not as confident on the
phone blah blah it's so easy to go if
like you was managing me and I was
looking at CV apply it now yeah like
you're looking for the thing that makes
you decide not to call the Natalie in it
making that decision in your mind
without even speaking to him right yeah
yeah do you not the best thing but the
worst thing for that is the best and the
worst thing which has happened to me
before still happens to me to now
sometimes and actually one of the best
things to keep me on my toes is when a
candidate that I know in my network who
I know pretty well I decided wasn't good
for a particular role then that
individual comes up on LinkedIn ping has
started at that client that easier that
and that is the biggest bite in the ass
you can get yeah for you to realize that
it you can never assume you just can't
because things change so quickly it's
and it's like I was saying before was
the amount of placements that I've made
speaking to candidates even about the
same job two or three months before who
said no but then two or three months
later things have changed have then gone
on taken the job it was it was it was
things like that which I think have
really spun it for me not being
complacent
you know complacent so we're not
assuming anything you know ensuring that
I'm speaking to my network making sure
I'm speaking to the best candidates
possible but never taking anything for
granted I think as soon as you do that
and get complacent it's like you say you
can make you can make the tiniest look
excluding your head not during a
candidate and that's it then then that
they're off your list how do you how do
you catch yourself doing that nothing
because I'm sure so you managing I'll
see bit associates blah blah blah yeah
how do you ensure that you don't assume
because it's so easy to do it is so easy
to do and it's something that you try
and filter down to the to the associates
and you try and give them your own
experience yeah do you know what I've
done that before and it hurts when you
see that happen when the candidate joins
a client or calls you people is painful
it's money at affordable
it's money out your pocket and it's
happened to us before happen to us it's
about trying to as hard as possible to
limit it but it's it's you have to
correct you know do not assume call them
why you know why why would you think
they wouldn't oh well they might be at
the budget or blah blah blah whatever it
might be you know how many times have
you know if you've got a good
relationship you client you can get your
clients to try an increase the budget
you know you could then try and get the
candidate a dream off for the candidate
there probably can be willing to take a
little bit less so you doing this to
yourself I'm sure that you might need
cuz I knew I needed my managed to do
this a lot hundred when we get people
like my old manager you should be like
so why haven't you call this person and
I have to justify what happens and it's
like sometimes so you need to be having
that conversation with yourself how do
you if you've got really you got to
catch yourself if you've if you yeah
it's just been able to have that
internal dialogue and be like yeah okay
so I'll just mint decision not to call
this person why my mentor always said
was you know what is your gut saying
right and your gut and if you if you if
you're if your gut is if you're trying
to get out of calling someone if you're
trying to make an assumption but your
gut if you've got to settle but you have
to call this person you just got to go
with it and it's bit about being honest
to yourself yeah you know if the worst
thing is to see candidates chew on your
clients and what I mean and you can't
you can't afford to do that because it's
a phone call it's a phone call if you've
got a relationship with a candidate
already yeah you ask them you know the
amount of times this is very quick
market cybersecurity market
software sales and general enterprise
sales things can change so so quickly
that candidates could say no to you one
week and literally the next week it
could be completely different air
anything else oh we were talking about
mate like working job that you can fill
making sure you're working with clients
who are engaged and and as we said come
come obviously make money out those
relationships don't assume don't assume
anything else mate the place comes up
for you in terms of again like I said I
think for me a big difference was was
when I was 1 always prepared to go above
and beyond and become a bit more use the
word obsessed with it that that is where
where it came for me was that you know
when I was doing work or researching
outside of work hours you know when I
was prepared
you know take a short a lunch break or
you know just just doing whatever I
could to give myself the opportunity you
know working more I was getting more
candidates in just giving myself every
chance I could to ensure that I filled a
role that I got my my pipeline big
enough to close as much as possible and
I think as soon as you make that the
commitment to to do what others won't
that is when you'll see a big difference
you know and and you know it's it's
tough it's difficult but when you went
when it clicks and it changes and I
think a lot of recruits have that light
bulb Eureka moment where I know wow it
all changed it's you know it then you
start getting all the benefits and you
know achieving the success and the
buildings where it may be with it
whatever your idea of success is as soon
as you start achieving that it becomes
like a drug and you just want to keep
doing it and doing it we talk about his
mindset and worker fit mindset and work
ethic I think that is a you know you
know a big thing is to listen is to piss
to listen right to your to your mentor
whoever your manager is you know if you
believe in them you trust in them and
they put the the belief in bringing you
on board you know listen to what they've
got to say it's so important because
salespeople often depending where you're
coming from whether it's from
recruitment background or whatever else
you know you you often think you know
everything a lot of people do you know
and you know as soon as you listen take
things on board be open to learning you
know that that was a big thing for me as
well big big time and and I think that's
a big thing for everybody else out there
is if you want to if you really want to
make it happen
the mindset being consistent you know
making sure you speaking to candidates
this is this is a job that you've got a
cool people you know you've got to get
on the phone you got to speak to people
yeah it's so important you know it's
it's it's not it's not about who's got
the the best call times every day the
best call stat so it's obviously quality
who you're speaking to and the kind of
conversations you having but you know
you're not going to get anywhere if you
don't if you don't speak to candidates
you know if you don't speak to the
market that's where you'll learn
everything and I love that may and then
just to add to that point at the live
event Tony who was on the panel he said
he quoted
book called legacy which is the All
Blacks
yeah and I'm one of the things that you
said which I think it's great and and
sort of as to your point should be
interesting to get to get your point on
this is like where like their sort of
commitment was always when they're at
the top of their game like always open
to evolve and always though yeah a bit
you know I mean have to be sits that's a
lie I can sense from you it's like okay
so I might hit this mark but that
doesn't mean that I know it all and you
know that's you've not be prepared to
you you have to be in and you know what
it's and again it coming from what I saw
myself at previous companies what you
know the mentor my mentor you know
seeing how much he build and you always
have to be willing to learn take things
on board there's there is you know I'm
still relatively fresh into my
recruitment career I think I think yeah
really I am I don't think I'm there's no
there's so much more room for
improvement and you have to be willing
and have that mindset it's very easy to
have a good month a good quarter a good
year you you really are you know
performing a level or that top level
when you are doing it quartering core
out year in year out that is when you've
mastering your market and you know I've
got ambitions to do better you know I
want to do better next year you know I
want to build more I want to bring more
clients and that that for me is I'm
always looking and striving to do better
and that I don't think that'll stop and
that's a big thing for me personally as
lawyers are that I was always very
competitive I've come from likes quite a
sporting background I played sports to
quite high level I was very you know
inter you know individual and team
sports and that ingrained it in me right
but I think the thing with the
recruitment is because it's quite
entrepreneurial in it and it's it's all
it's all a direct everything that you
gain is directly from your effort and
your impact then it becomes you start
seeing actually well if I put in that
energy if I put in that effort you know
if I make sure I'm consistent every day
things grow and that's why it's a
business within a business and again
it's it's there's so many cliches and
recruitment but they're all there for a
reason because they're true and it's
about what you can make of it on when
you're on Team Commission
[Laughter]
- having it that is worse and well and
it's it's you know what it's and when I
say about committing to it and becoming
obsessed it's there's when I stopped you
know you know partying is March 9 going
out and having a good time and
everything enjoy my family and friends
but when I started thinking to myself
actually you know if I do go out and if
I do come in and have two or three days
or I'm still catching up myself so I'm
feeling a little bit rough or it might
be you know that that those little
chunks they take up ya know you add them
all up right yeah all right couple
things before we finish yep
BD ya always talk about on here just
because it's it's a as I'm sure you've
experienced in people around you people
that you hire now it's a hard part the
job definitely difficult part for me
obviously as you said you from your
prior experience getting into
recruitment you've been in the b2b world
you've always been on the phone your
business etc etc so obviously from what
from sort of our relationship and wonder
about you you see and you have a focus
on BD and that's a big contributor to
you and billing more etc so let's just
talk a bit about sort of your
perspective on business development I
mean firstly from the associate I know
well so you've got a model where people
deliver and focus on candidates etc but
typically what are some of the things
that you you see or feel like people do
on the BD front that sort of prevents
them from having that six did you know I
mean I think you've got to I personally
believe that actually bringing on a role
isn't as hard as people think I think
bringing on clients and bring on a role
is actually easier than filling it
that's my personal belief right I think
people and consultants and we have it
where we've got associates and consults
in the moment who were making that
transition in their journey from going
from a delivery consultant into looking
into career and it's about it's about
the process you have it's about how do
you approach it I don't think that the
big thing for me the big difference for
me was when I stopped looking at hire
managers and big big titles and big
names
as people that one approachable people
that would would not speak to me that
wouldn't answer the phone what changed
that that the mindset was just that I
what I started doing was treating them
as a candidate yeah as soon as I started
treating a client as a candidate I could
I could extract all the information I
needed yeah I could understand more
about them I could I could actually
offer them a bit more value when I was
talking on their level is not someone
that just wanted something from them
someone was actually prepared to speak
to them and understand what they might
be looking for when they move you know I
think too many be deep or individuals
recruiters that are trying to move into
Bedi you know they're cold cooling and
they're just going straight in for the
kill they're going straight in trying to
you know pick up roles and you know I
just don't think that's the best
approach I think as soon as you start
treating them like a client and building
so as a candidate and building long-term
relationships and again I said this
before about you know with candidates
were four I've not may have placed a
candidate two or three months off the
first time I spoke to them about a
particular role or where they might said
no the same thing applies for a client
you know you're not always gonna in a
score a goal on the first shot right you
have to be prepared to play a little bit
the long game keep in touch you know say
you'll follow up when you say you're
gonna follow up yeah you know think
again two things changing their world a
lot so it's there's so many things that
need you need to consider but but a lot
of recruiters will not do what they say
they're going to do so if you say you're
gonna follow up if you're going to keep
in contact you know follow up when you
say you're gonna follow up and I think
that's come up a couple of times I would
then do you do you book it do you say
right do you agree there then on the
call lutely a great there and then on a
call you know I make sure I stay in
contact with the watch that and then you
put me on your diary my diary just keep
contact you know share personal interest
you know keep keep close to them talk
you know discussing actually things
about the mark in their industry that
are relevant gaining their feedback on
things and it's a relationship and you
know if you want to become a trusted
partner it has to be a much more you
know how to run a deeper level than just
transactional yeah and I think as soon
as you start getting relationships with
these individuals and they begin to
trust you more and it's more than just a
on a transactional level things will
change and then you'll be the first
person they think about again there's
times when I've had you know clients
that it's taken me you know six months
or a year to convert which is a long
time but then they become some of our
biggest clients yeah
it's about it's about you know the
approach it's about doing what you say
you're going to do keeping in touch with
them keeping in contact taking interest
in speaking being a mastery market so
you mentioned they're around obviously a
lot of people typically just go straight
in for the kill you're talking about
here fire if I'm you're in my market and
I see Ali he's a CEO and I call him in a
sly alley I'm a specialist for Korea bla
bla bla like have you got any jobs right
that's what you talking about
mmm how do you typically approach your
now then I think there's a time and a
place for that I think if you speak to
candidates who are actively interviewing
and their interview that they tell you
they're interviewing with a company that
you're not working with for its
particular role that you know you've got
candidates for definitely show in front
it can be it can be as simple as that it
can be and and it depends on their need
how urgent is that need for them if if
they're desperate the likelihood is the
hire manager will say yeah just send me
the can I'll have a look at them you
know if they're good the Seavey's good
and I'll interview them and it can be
don't get me where but but more from the
nights probably isn't but I think it's a
good approach is to be targeted and
understanding where the need is so if
you do know that that companies are
looking for particular individual in a
particular territory if you know that
they use agencies you know if you know
that they engage with external
headhunters to help support them you can
be targeted about your approach you can
you know a lot of the times I've had and
brought on new clients off the back of
you know doing senior hires so when I've
had big senior hires and for some of my
clients and I've reached out to the
market for you know senior leaders you
mean got flipping them from camp yeah
yeah you you you you know it is if you
if you get a short list of ten
candidates and one of them gets a job
you've got nine other candidates there
that you've built up a good relationship
with and shown them your process showing
them how you deal with the candidate
showing them the kind of detail you go
into and and then it's a much easier
conversation to go into
look you know you know are you hiring
you know what you know last time we
spoke you mentioned that you got head
count coming up for the next year or
you're replacing someone you're finding
it difficult it's always that that
always seems like a bit of a quite
effective way to yeah I think it's it's
it's it's you know it's not it's not new
it works it works and you know at the
end of the day if if it ain't broke
don't fix it but I think I think the key
part there is that mindset shift of
making sure you don't look at hiring
managers see is another human being and
I promise you now what's so interesting
and I say it's all the the associates
and consultants and moving through into
a 360 is I get the best response for
particular jobs when they're senior
leaders I find that I get a better
response rate when I'm reaching out to
candidates for senior leadership roles
then when I do for just a an account
manager in a particular region low 80s
and when you reach out to Athenian
people when you're talking to them about
potential job are they exactly if I've
got a senior would you would you make up
a job or would you always do any job
let's be real a bit of both totally
agree you know I'll be honest about it
it's it's a bit of both
but it is it's it's so interesting to
see that the senior leaders you you
build up this you kind of put them on
such a pedestal where yeah there's so
much and often look these guys are so
busy man you know they're they haven't
got time to the barely speak to their
family let alone another recruiter but
when you go to them with a senior level
job it is so interesting to see how how
many them respond its takes its own it's
so interesting ok that brings me on to
the last sort of point I'd be stupid to
not talk to you about this mate because
obviously we've been doing and some
stuff together
I think this sides quite nicely with the
BD stuff right comes a plug but I've
said you know I'm really passionate
about personal branding so I think let's
just just talk a bit about sort of your
experience in not doing overly loads a
bit on LinkedIn yeah like the typical
recruiter yeah - now you've you've
become really consistently sharing
videos but
so let's just focus on the beady piece
like how how was sort of UW consistently
sharing content amongst with the
headhunting and you didn't we're talking
about how is it how is it impacted
massively yes why is it so light in
terms of speaking to people off the back
of videos there did you know I mean I've
had as you know like you saw the success
I've had you know even within the first
day at the first hour yeah but it's what
what the entry think the part that you
brought that that I think people know
but again it's not committing to it and
you know you you're you're opening your
eyes to using LinkedIn as a source to
project to the market to your network
yourself your brand because at the end
of the day people are buying people
right yeah think about recruitment is
that people buy the the individual and
not necessarily the brand name so you
could therefore any name and and what
you've done and I think that the it the
impact its had on on you know what I'm
doing is you know I'm doing things
differently to what other recruiters are
doing especially in my space and in what
was interesting what you brought to my
attention was that a lot of my
competitors I won't do anything so it's
been able to feed everything talking
about actually just the point because I
think Hunnam sending everyone in terms
of BD keep keep doing what you do I just
said don't you don't need to fix
something that isn't broken oh do all of
that but then at the same time you have
an amazing tool right now in terms of
LinkedIn and you can start showing their
opinion and so that that's just huge for
me that people understand and that's
also a tool in your arsenal yeah that
you can use janilla and okay mate as we
finish yes what I wanted to ask you was
one thing actually yeah because I've
been asked a lot about it recently so
I've always just mentioned it at the end
counteroffers yes
well spending experience like that in
the because I've had quite a few message
recently saying
hisham I've really felt that like
counteroffers have become like yeah
they've been more prevalent than they
have been in the last year or so effects
because the Breck's here never
you know how what's been your soar
perspective I mean yeah I've been stung
a few times if I'm honest but but the
but the interesting thing is and this
statistics around this is you know
if someone I think counteroffers you've
always got to speak to the candidate
about and and reminding about the
reasons they're looking in the first
place I think it's a statistic out there
and I think it's above 80 percent that
candidates who accept the counteroffer
from their current employer will leave
their job within six months I think it's
like I just like I've seen so many so
many recruiters do content on this yeah
and the percentage changes all the time
okay so do you say that to candidates
I've used I've used the number yes but
at the same time it's you have to remind
them what you know why they're looking
because money if it was about money the
likelihood is if the if your client who
wants to hire that can that I really
wants them and in a business their
current employer comes in with a
counteroffer if your client really wants
them there is a chance that you they'll
will stretch their budget to try and
match that or more there is always that
chance but if you're if it's about the
money then you can get more money but if
it's about more than that you know it's
identifying the pain and often that pain
could be you know you're not getting on
with their manager so if they accept the
counteroffer they're still not gonna go
with managers there's so many comes back
to the beginning like you need to know
what their drivers are reason for
leaving what that's that's the bottom of
that because money's my money's never no
money's not going to solve that problem
is not gonna change it I mean were you
excited about for the future
yeah man so many things we're growing
we've got you know we've got our plans
we've got plans to to to grow you know
cross us across different territories
you know inviting new people into the
business we've got you know it's it's
such an office and bright and I've also
been to Brian office you have it you've
just got the place next door to the
place next door swell yeah well it's my
intimating it's getting people in that
could be more yeah we've we just were a
really exciting time
it's did a big learning curve for me for
me personally but really excited to
continue my personal
my growth you know working with you with
my personal branding they're the
possibilities it's it's a really
exciting time and definitely for me
personally right now it's my career
these are the highlights of my career at
the moment somebody's in my dad's here
so last question I always ask people
yeah before we finish yep
so you can answer this question with a
word or phrase whatever comes to mind
right so it is if Ali could communicate
to every single recruiter out there
they'd listen their take on an advice
they'd implement it tomorrow
yep what would you say to them mate I
would say the most important thing is
and again I said it before I do is be a
master of your market be the master of
your market and candidates will come to
you clients will come to you you there's
there's no there's no way you will not
earn money I've got me there you go
great story Ali thank you thanks a
minute